[Music]  oh  [Music]  we know two people have been killed and  eight people have been injured but it's  unclear how they were killed and injured  from residents accounts they say that  somebody actually stabbed a taliban  fighter and in the chaos the taliban  started shooting and then there was a  stampede and  there was also a similar incident in  jalalabad just east of kabul where a  crowd gathered and  two people were shot  by the taliban there  [Music]  there are a lot of people in the cities  and especially in kabul and other places  where they are very disheartened  by the takeover of taliban and also that  they would never like  them to impose their rule on them so i  think they will find an opportunity to  represent and i think it could take a  turn if the taliban also tried to be  very harsh on them  [Music]  yes  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]